starting off this hour is gonna be me I
in California I'm a a welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
I'm so happy my call was accepted today
sure thank you
thank you how can I help and so I took a
CH a Financial Peace University our last
year and as of this past May I've been
working really hard on baby step 2 I am
I am a registered nurse and I have a
daughter that I am we share custody I'm
a single mom I prior to taking your
program I was contributing 8% into my
retirement account so that I could get a
4% match however of course your program
except to not contribute because you've
got to maximize your your income to pay
off your debt which I have been however
I I'm 53 and I reached out to a
financial advisor and also my tax
accountant because I'm worried about
with increased income that I'm not
getting the pre-tax savings so I'm
worried that now at the end of the year
I'm gonna have to pay taxes now so all
that money that I was coming towards my
my debt my credit card debt now I'm
gonna have to pay taxes so the tax
advisor said that I make pretty good
money that I should be able to do both
now your tax advisor is an idiot thank
you okay no I mean wait listen the
program that you went through has taught
six million people to get out of that so
you just have to decide which program
are you going to use your tax
accountants are the one that you were
taught your even taught all the reasons
that we say this now how much debt do
you have left
I have 23,000 okay and what is your
household income um I was at 120 but I'm
now at 150 amazing little when will your
little $23,000 debt be paid with your
big $150,000 income well that that's
just this this year because it's May
I've been working overtime
well your twenty three thousand be paid
off um well my strategic plan is
hopefully in a year if I just keep this
as oh why would it take a year to pay
off twenty three thousand when you make
150 oh should it take less yeah six
months well that money of going 150 is
me working night shift working extra
yeah so we're next rent pay it off
that's what we taught you
yes are we talking about six months here
okay but that it's not a guaranteed
paycheck because it has to be because
I'm a nurse and so we have to have the
patient in the need so it doesn't
there's a little bit of fluctuation with
time kind of if I were sensitive so what
were you putting in your 401k I was
putting 8% 8% so $8,000 taxes on $8,000
you would be saving $2000 so all of this
discussion is about $2,000 while you
make 150 I went by the way it's not even
really $2,000 because you need to roll
up your sleeves and get this done in six
months so it's $1,000 because you're
gonna do it in half a year so look there
is no way to scheme and scam your way
through this
the
way you do it as you throw a brick
through the window you have to get
violent about it and you haven't yet
you're still trying to intellectually
trick these this math and the math works
this way you will be out of debt when
you pay twenty three thousand dollars
off and it's the faster you concentrate
on that the faster you're going to be
able to move on with wealth building and
people who try to do three things at
once don't get any of them done these
are the things we taught you when you
went through financial peace I kind of
think you flunked you may need to go
back this is all about behavior it's all
about getting gazelle and tents it's all
about focus the angrier you are the more
you focus the deeper you sacrifice the
faster you get out the more you
intellectually rationalize and have
these mathematically irrelevant
discussions with tax advisers about
2,000 freaking dollars while you make a
hundred and fifty and city or broke at
53 years old so you've got to decide
what you're going to do but this is
about focus and the faster you get out
of debt the faster you're gonna have
money to aggressively invest and what
little ground you lose while you were
beginning while you have stopped all of
your retirement savings while you get
out of debt will be made up in no time
at all and you really need a new tax
advisor or at least one that doesn't
give financial advice that he doesn't
know what the crap he's talking about
that simple hope that helps